good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it was a week ago today
that a deranged teenager called salvador
ramos murdered 19 children and two
teachers in an elementary school in
texas you know this because we've had
seven days of full saturation coverage
and it's all deserved given that it's
amazing what we still don't know about
what happened that day
let's start just because it's the most
obvious with how the shooter could
possibly have afforded the firearms he
used salvador ramos was 18 years old he
worked part-time at the drive-through at
a local wendy's yet police say he had at
least four thousand dollars of brand new
weapons including two ar-15 rifles 1600
rounds of 556 ammunition a ballistic
vest and 60 magazines
one of ramos's rifles was a high-end
model manufactured by a company called
daniel defense
according to a receipt that ramos posted
in a private message that gun cost two
thousand dollars and he paid in full now
ramos could have bought effectively the
very same rifle at any gun store for a
third of the cost
but apparently to ramos price was no
object
that's pretty weird
if police know where ramos got the money
to buy one of the most expensive ar-15s
on the market they're not telling us
nor for that matter have they explained
why they lied about the most basic facts
of the shooting for the first 24 hours
they told us that a school resource
officer fired at the gunman he quote
engaged ramos but they must have known
at the time they said it that that was
not true they must know the re the
resource officer was not even at the
school when ramos arrived
but they told us otherwise why'd they do
that
and by the way how long was ramos
outside the school firing his gun at
people at a nearby funeral home before
he went inside and killed children
that seems like a fairly simple question
certainly an important question last
week authorities told us that ramos was
outside the school for 10 to 12 minutes
here's the claim
we got a crash
and a man with a gun
they have responding officers
that's what it is it is 12 minutes
from 11 30 to 11 40.
that's the information we have
12 minutes from 11 30 to 11 40. that's
the information we have quote but that
information is clearly wrong because 11
30 to 11 40 is not 10 minutes the
timeline matters so what's the real
timeline
well on friday the director of texas dps
came up with a brand new timeline here
it is
11 28
the suspect vehicle crashes into the
ditch as previously described
the teacher runs to the room 132 to
retrieve a phone and that same team
teacher walks back to the exit door and
door remains propped open at 11 33 the
suspect begins shooting into room 111
or 112. it's not possible to determine
from the video angle that we have at
this point in time
so actually and that was the director of
public safety in texas it was only five
minutes that ramos was outside shooting
at people okay
but here's the key takeaway from that
statement here's what they want you to
believe the back door to the school was
open
because a teacher at the school left it
open after going outside to retrieve a
phone
so it's the teacher's fault that ramos
was able to get inside that's what they
said on friday
but this too appears to be untrue the
houston chronicle is reporting tonight
that surveillance footage of the school
shows that the teacher slammed the door
after running back inside and of course
that would make sense since by this
point ramos was firing his rifle and
that same teacher was using the phone in
question to make a panicked call to
no one disputes that
so why did the authorities tell us
otherwise
and for that matter why did they
initially deny that the on-scene police
commander ordered cops to stand down and
remain outside as children were being
shot to death inside the school
on thursday a spokesman for texas dps
called that account
a rumor quote but there was videotape to
show that it was true it actually
happened so the next day forced by the
videotape texas dps admitted the rumors
were true watch
what happened with the officers
or another door
get inside that classroom
none at that time
why why the
the on-scene commander at the time
believed that it had transitioned from
an active shooter to a barricaded
subject
say please send the police
they are alive in that classroom there
are lives that are at risk
we're well aware of that
obviously
obviously you know based upon the
information we have there were children
in that classroom that were at risk and
it was in fact still an active shooter
situation and not a barricaded subject
but that's not really an explanation of
course because no one disputes that
everyone on the scene including police
knew that ramos had weapons was firing
them at people to kill people and was
inside the school with children
no one disputes that so why did heavily
armed police units decide not to stop
salvador ramos from executing children
now it's not finger-pointing to ask that
question these are very complicated
circumstances people are under immense
pressure people make mistakes
but
we are making long-term policy decisions
based on the specifics of what happened
last week in uvalde politicians across
this country are calling for
militarizing america's elementary
schools
and yet they can't answer why the
military force effectively outside this
elementary school
refused to stop
the killing so this massacre could have
been prevented at some point it was not
prevented why was that
we should know the answer but don't hold
your breath
no one in power seems anxious to hold
themselves accountable for what happened
in uvalde and amazingly
and this is so perverse it's hard to
believe it's true but it is
some seem determined to make future
school shootings more likely
in california the state assembly just
voted to end the requirement
the long-standing requirement that was
put in place after school shootings that
schools alert law enforcement when
students quote attack assault or
physically threaten school officials
that's no longer in place and according
to the democratic party that's a win for
equity
we know this because the sponsor of the
bill a california state senator called
steven bradford said so here's what he
told the daily caller quote black
students latin ex students students of
color and students with disabilities are
disproportionately referred to law
enforcement cited and arrested end quote
so too many latinx students in
wheelchairs apparently are being blamed
for school shootings so there's no more
violence reporting in california schools
at all
so how does that help prevent the next
school shooting well of course it
doesn't
but it's starting to seem like helping
prevent school shootings is not really
the point of this exercise amassing more
power is the point
and we know this from what's happening
north of us canada's botox dictator
justin trudeau wasted no time in using
the tragedy in the u.s to his own
political advantage in canada now uvalde
is more than 2 000 miles from ottawa but
because of what salvador ramos was
allowed to do in texas canadians are no
longer allowed to protect themselves
justin trudeau has introduced a bill
that would ban canadian citizens from
buying selling and transferring handguns
within their own country
again handguns were not the cause of the
shooting in uvalde ufaldi's nowhere near
canada
and yet justin trudeau is using that
tragedy
to disarm anyone who disagrees with him
by the way that law would empower courts
to
confiscate guns from people even if
they've not committed a crime
watched justin trudeau announce this
power grab and as you do watch pay
special attention to the masked toadies
behind him nodding in unison
we're introducing legislation to
implement a national freeze
on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import
handguns
anywhere in
canada in other words
we're capping the market
what's actually happening here is that
people like justin trudeau know that
their rule is illegitimate they know
perfectly well how resented they are and
they spend an awful lot of time thinking
about civil unrest you probably don't
you live in a democracy so you don't
imagine that anyone needs to be disarmed
for political reasons but people like
justin trudeau can feel
the deep resentment aimed at them
and they are fully intent on disarming
the population
now we reached out to justin trudeau's
office today about this new law we
wanted to know if trudeau will apply
these laws to himself that's always the
first and most important test of sin of
sincerity if it's good for me it ought
to be good for you too and vice versa
so in this case will justin trudeau's
state-funded bodyguards be relinquishing
their handguns and how about their
banned ar-15s
but of course we're not allowed to know
the answers to that question because
he's in power and we're not quote we do
not comment on matters related to the
prime minister's security his office
responded meaning of course not justin
trudeau isn't that stupid he's going to
continue to protect his own family
you're just not going to be allowed to
protect yours in canada
now here in the united states as always
democrats are watching very carefully
what trudeau is up to as they plan our
future here
and already the rhetoric of the
democratic party has changed for years
democrats joe biden his supporters the
media have talked about banning ar-15s
the so-called weapons of war which are
not in fact used by any military but
weapons of war have been their focus
watch
venom of the haters
and their weapons of war
assault style weapons that are weapons
of war and purchase these weapons of war
to get these weapons of war finally
ridding our streets
of weapons of war what we should be
doing is taking these weapons of war out
of the hands of civilians because they
see what these weapons of war do on the
street an assault weapon is a weapon of
war
with no place
no place in a civil society
they wouldn't know what end the bullet
comes out of they know nothing about
this topic they don't even know the
basic crime stats in the united states
rifles kill fewer people every year than
fists or knives do there's no effort
afoot to ban knives or fists
but weapons of war have long been
their focus meaning ar-15s the single
most popular self-defense rifle in the
united states self-defense is the point
on sunday congressman adam kinzinger
has decided and says it out loud that in
order for him to feel safe we're going
to need to confiscate your rifle because
he feels unsafe watch congressman you do
still oppose
a ban on the kind of assault weapons
that were used in the shooting can you
explain why private citizens need
weapons of war
look i have opposed a ban uh you know
fairly recently i i think i'm open to a
ban now
can you explain congressman why private
citizens need weapons of war now cnn
anchors need to be surrounded by
bodyguards with weapons of war because
they're important but you and your
family no you don't need weapons of war
so for years it's been about the ar-15
but things are changing
joe biden is now calling for a ban on
the ubiquitous nine millimeter round
watch this
a nine millimeter bullet
blows the lung out of the body
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is that
there's simply no rational basis for it
in terms of
about
self-protection hunting
and
i guess and remember
the constitution the second amendment
was never absolute
you couldn't buy a cannon when the
second amendment was back
so there's a guy who can't even
recognize his own wife of 40 years in
public lecturing us about what the
rational basis is for this without the
quote there's simply no rational basis
for the nine millimeter round in terms
of self-protection
well of course the opposite is true the
nine millimeter is the main
self-protection round in the united
states along with the 556 the round used
in the ar-15 both of them are small
rounds
people use them to protect their
families and if you take them away
americans will no longer be able to
defend themselves in the middle of a
crime wave that was wholly manufactured
by the same people who are trying to
strip your guns from you and that's of
course the point this is a power grab
and you can be certain that it is a
power grab and not an effort to make
this a safer country because the people
who are calling for it are exempting
themselves from its requirements once
again that is the acid test
if you're for a law
will it apply to you
do michael bloomberg's bodyguards carry
the dreaded nine millimeter or two two
three rounds do they have high capacity
magazines do nancy pelosi's bodyguards
which you pay for do mitch mcconnell's
bodyguards carry those rounds
well we wanted to know why wouldn't we
want to know why don't we have a right
to know so we emailed all three of their
offices today
and unlike we have to say justin
trudeau's office none of them even
bothered to reply to us
so obviously they won't be disarming
their own bodyguards
they'll keep their own weapons of war in
the meantime they'll continue to pass
legislation against weapons they know
nothing about they've been doing this
for decades
we did a documentary on this actually
and we spoke to
probably the person who's more about
self-defense weapons than any living
american hiccup 45
one of the most popular figures on
youtube and truly an expert on the use
of firearms for self-defense
here's part of what he told us
and of course it has the the famous uh
tucker carlson barrel shroud on it
barrel shroud guns hickok 45 is
referring to congresswoman carolyn
mccarthy of new york who famously didn't
understand the firearm she was trying to
ban do you know what a barrel shot
particularly
i actually don't know what a barrel
shotgun
that goes up no it's not sure makes the
rifle more deadly right yeah really
shrouds that barrel
you know a lot of what people come up
with that do not know firearms they just
do not like them they hate them and you
know so they're looking for reasons to
hate them they don't know anything about
the cartridges a bullet is dangerous
let's face it a hammer a chainsaw a
ladder a car
they're potentially dangerous
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight